mes chers collègues
des nuits d'une rare violence ont marqué
notre pays depuis une semaine
les mères les élus locaux en première
ligne ont été encore une fois le rempart
de la République
aux côtés de nos forces de l'ordre de
nos sapeurs-pompiers et de nos polices
municipales
la mort d'un jeune est évidemment un
drame mais rien ne peut justifier les
émeutes les agressions et menaces contre
les élus le pillage l'incendie de nos
mairies de nos écoles de le commissariat
ou de commerce
l'ordre républicain doit être établi et
les anciennement de ce qui s'est passé
devront être tirés
le Sénat s'y engagera pleinement dans sa
mission temps de législateur comme de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
afin que soit faite la lumière sur ces
événements qu'on soit tirés les
enseignants les enseignements et que
nous puissions faciliter faciliter pour
nos élus locaux le redressement de
situation aujourd'hui insupportable
enfin mes chers collègues je veux en
autre nom à tous apporter notre soutien
à tous ceux citoyens commerçants élus
locaux forces de sécurité de secours qui
ont été visés ou directement atteints
par ces violences voilà la déclaration
que je souhaitais faire avant que nous
abordions notre ordre du jour
[Musique]